five four three two one
boom and we're live thanks for doing
this man I appreciate it
hey thank you for having me I appreciate
that he's the only guy I've ever had in
the studio where when I showed up you
were working out that's what I do mask
my life that's my life it's pretty crazy
though I mean how much time did you have
when you got here I got here about an
hour early oh yeah okay so I got here
shirt off doing chin up hilarious I
think if I camera out in time for you
song I wanted to take some pictures well
maybe next time
next time well catch you after the show
you are a guide that for a lot of people
you sort of embody the idea of hardening
your mind and figuring out a way to do
things that most people think are
impossible
all right let's you've sort of become
that guy over your life and you've
become that guy for a lot of people
including me online we've talked about
you on the podcast a ton of times so
having you in here has been it's very
exciting to me I appreciate that thank
you how'd you become that guy you know
what I grew up not that guy yeah so a
lot of people put a title on me they
want to they see me now they see me now
as the guy that with his shirt off who
can do 4030 pull-ups in 17 hours you can
run tours in five miles in 39 hours who
can do all this crazy [ __ ] but what they
don't understand is they don't
understand the journey that it took me
to get to this point and what got me to
this point was I was just the opposite
everything the day I was that guy who
ran away from absolutely everything that
I got in front of me but not many people
knew that I had two people at the like
the real me was like this very scared
insecure stuttering got beat up by his
dad all this kind of stuff and I built
this fake person that walked around like
my [ __ ] didn't stink you know you know
that yeah so that was that's kind of how
I did it and I do the process of time I
realized that I was lying to myself and
lying to people but that it's a
fascinating journey though because
you are that guy now Ryan you genuinely
are legit badass right at one point in
time you were a legit terrified person
yes so what was the process like how did
how did you step forth well it's a it's
a long process right um I my dad beat
the [ __ ] I mean was growing up we I was
the first black baby born in this
hospital called Millard Fillmore in
Buffalo New York my dad owned skating
rinks he owned bars he ran prostitutes
from Canada to Buffalo New York my dad
was a big-time pimp big-time anything
bad about a person
big-time hustler he was American you
know that I'm with them Denzel
Washington he was that but not that bad
right yeah he wasn't that big but that's
what it reminds me of he was that kind
of guy and beat the [ __ ] out of me did
she help you no I love my mom there was
an instant one time when my mom got
knocked out on top of stairs and they
drug her down the stairs by her hair at
six years old
I'll never forget this in my mind I was
always afraid my whole life I was afraid
but I had this [ __ ] voice this this
conscience that would always be battling
me said hey you got to get up and do
something I didn't want to do [ __ ] you
know I was just afraid but I would that
that voice would forced me to get up and
my dad you know I try to beat him up
whatever at six and I get my ass kicked
so this went on for several years and I
have a big time learning disability can
my dad didn't believe in us going to
school so my dad it was about the
business the skating rink in the bar so
this game you open about seven o'clock
at night and this is when time I was
able to walk so about five you know four
or five six years old eight nine and I
go to the skating rink it's ten o'clock
at night and I worked the skating rink
until 10:00 at night and then we would
scrape the gum off the floors and we
cleaned the whole skating rink up and
then my dad at the office and my brother
and myself asleep in the office and my
mama go upstairs and worked the bar
until three o'clock in the morning and
then they cleaned the bar up so after
all that [ __ ] was done with going to
school really happened so when I went to
school I was all kind of you know my
learning disability I had social anxiety
I was just a jacked up kid from living
in this tour
at home from the outside looking in we
live in the all-white neighborhood and
then we would travel to the ghetto of
Buffalo New York with the skating rink
was that so we you know we worked around
mostly blacks and I lived around mostly
White's but no one knew what was going
on the house that on 201 Paradise Road
yeah it's crazy but um my mom got
courage to finally leave him when I was
by 8 years old we moved to a small town
in Brazil Indiana and that's when the
real war started for me and Brazilian is
a small town great people a lot of great
people and I say that because like
people get offended and I'm gonna get to
the point where they get offended there
was about maybe 10 black families at
about 10,000 people in the town and in
1995 the KKK marched in the 4th of July
parade so this was a not every bar was
racist there's a lot of good people some
the best people I knew was there but
there's also a lot of racism there so me
being one of the few black kids net you
know in the area you know it kind of
haunts you I had stuff on my notebook
you know [ __ ] we're gonna kill you on
my Spanish notebook they had that on my
car [ __ ] this is early 90s and so even
though I sold it didn't hurt me
it was jacking me up so all the
insecurities I have when I was a kid
with my father I moved into this area
here and it just got worse and worse and
worse and it [ __ ] haunted me and that
voice that talked about it kept talking
louder and louder and louder I was doing
nothing about it and I decided to make
moves and I cheated all through school
and it's kind of humbling to talk with
my stories sometimes in this um it's
also embarrassing but it's real it's who
the [ __ ] I am is what I am is what
created me and copy from the fourth
grade to the to my junior year in high
school on every assignment and I want to
get in the military I'm gonna join the
airforce and the guy gave me an as vapp
test as I could water down SAT and I
couldn't copy on it because the guy
beside me how to test a test B they got
him I write he had test C so I looked
the copy on this test and I couldn't
copy on so I got like a 20 and I wanted
to be an Air Force pararescueman it's
guys that jump out of airplanes and save
down pilots it's a
it's a special operator in the Air Force
and my squirt was so horribly low that
is we take it again
and he said hey I got an 18 the second
time even worse I need to get a 50 out
of a 99 and so a mom and I for a while
we lived in the government subsidized
apartments seven dollars a month and
also food stamps and we slowly moved up
to a $230 a month place but at the time
you know we you know pretty poor but um
my mom afforded enough money for me to
go to see a tutor one one hour a week so
for four hours a month it had six months
to study from our last test I can only
take the best you know the answer to
test three times and I studied my ass
off and passed it I got in the Air Force
and realized there was more things in
front of me I was afraid of water
terrified the water and I've learned how
to swim but what gets everybody in this
training in all special ops training is
the water confidence where they try to
pretty much drowned your ass you know
all of our lives we've been breathing
and they take that from you and they
want to see how comfortable you are in
the water and there's a 1%
african-americans in Special Operations
and I didn't know anything about African
like a lot of them are negative buoyant
which I am because the bone density I
struggled but I'm six weeks into the
program there was about 25 guys left of
about 150 I was there and I was never I
didn't gonna sleep for six weeks of the
program and I wanted to quit so badly
but I quit everything in my life I
copied through school I want to prove
people wrong and so here I am in this
Air Force program start to get a little
more confidence but this water was
kicking my ass
and six weeks in the program the doctor
gave me a blood test and must have
sickle-cell sickle cell trait not the
anemia but I still killed people but so
they pulled me out training for a week
and when you go from being very
uncomfortable in that water situation
and then now you're comfortable and I'm
sitting back watching the guys drown I'm
not you know I'm not part of the
activities anymore for this week I don't
want to get back in that damn water
again so the fear overcame in all my
insecurities for my dad from this small
town from everything started coming back
and even though no one knew how [ __ ]
up I was kind of create this other
person
tough I live with this [ __ ] all time so
mean I wouldn't go back in that water
the doctor called me a backup I thought
to get like a like a medical kick out of
the military so no quitting for me they
kicked me out so I can have some pride
the doctor said no I'm kidding you know
we could put you back in the training
and I was like [ __ ] but after a week I'm
like you know what I missed one week
there's only three weeks left there's a
good chance you know I could tough this
[ __ ] out and go on but I went back to
the CEO and the commanding officer of
the program and the sergeant said hey
you gotta start from day one because you
missed you know that that week of
training and I broke
I broke I couldn't imagine going back
through that again
so I made up a lie and I said man
there's sickle-cell things really
scaring me it was the [ __ ] water it
wasn't sickle cell and and I pretty much
quit even though they gave me a medical
and I quit so um from the age of 19 days
of 22 I went into the job called tack
pee where you control fast movers behind
enemy lines cool job but there's no
water I was afraid of water so I've
avoided it and I gained 125 pounds in
that time frame
I went from 175 to almost 300 to 297 was
my heaviest and I started finding things
that was comfortable and the more things
I found comfortable the more
uncomfortable my mind was because that
voice I was telling you about it always
was there I was trying to avoid that
conscience I wanted to be left alone
from that conscience and it wouldn't
leave me alone so I got out of the Air
Force and I started working for a job
called ecolab respray for cockroaches at
24 and I'm spraying at different staking
sheiks Red Lobster whatever from 11
o'clock at night at 7 o'clock in the
morning and what changed I came home and
watch this Discovery Channel show class
224 I came home from Steak N Shake I
sprayed it down last get a big ol large
42 ounce shake walk across the street
and get a box of mini doughnuts from
7-eleven you never drive home for 45
minutes this big old fat guy who yeah I
worked out but I was fat I didn't run
didn't PT I just hit the gym so I'm
driving
home turn the TV on and what comes on
Discovery Channel so and that's what
everything changed for me I was taking a
shower I walked out heard these guys and
I watched the show and it made me
reflect big-time on the piece of [ __ ]
that I am and I'm exactly what people
said I was going to be so so what was on
this show that really struck home it was
um I saw these guys going into water so
I was terrified of it I can't even
express have you ever had a big fear and
I know a lot of fighters have fears and
stuff like that but they get over them
but all of us have these fears that you
just don't want to [ __ ] face and um I
have a lot of them had a lot of them and
that's what created the person who's in
front of today and we'll get into that
but I'm just a scared [ __ ] is what I
was and but I was watching these guys
going through hell week class 2:24 and
these guys ringing the bell quitting
dropping their helmet down rolling out a
lot of guys is leaving and it made me
reflect on my fears my insecurities and
I saw real men when I thought were real
men who were staying who were overcoming
adversity who were overcoming all these
different things that I had blamed so
many [ __ ] people in my life my dad my
mom for not being there when I was 14
years old my my mama's would get
remarried to this great guy he got
murdered and then I moved back to a
small town in Brazil and and I everybody
was a blame my learned disability my my
skin color you know me being everything
and so I sat there for a while and I was
like man I gotta [ __ ] I got it
no one's gonna [ __ ] come to help me
his [ __ ] me against me period and I'm
so I had to man up and I said first
thing I started doing is facing every
[ __ ] fear I have no matter what the
[ __ ] it is man and these things would
keep me up and that no one people who
are here in this [ __ ] day they will
never really understand and grasp when
you face these things and so many things
how they keep you up and haunts you at
night I think there's a lot of people
out there that know what you're talking
about I mean and so that's what it did
and I had two options to either be that
300-pound guy who spray for cockroaches
and
thousand dollars a month and at 24 years
old knowing we're not 50 [ __ ] years
old I can reflect on this and think
about what God never became or I can
totally just sack it up and fail and
fail and fail entire succeed so I
started calling recruiters up I said
we'll be a [ __ ] Navy SEAL and every
recruiter so there's a weight and height
so they weigh weight and height limit to
get in the military and I was 6 foot 1
and to 97 and I had prior service which
was a big deal so I called all these
recruiters up and all of them said hey
how tall are you bla bla they got into
conversation and see if I even qualified
and by the time I got to my weight phone
we were hanging up pretty much like hey
you know what call somebody else you
know try to get in the reserves so I
tried to get in the reserves and I
called this guy named Steven salad your
recruiter up and he said hey come on in
he saw me put me through the weight
standard all the sort of stuff and to
get into the class I had to get into how
to lose 106 pounds in less than 3 months
so I was like [ __ ] that I can't do that
I grabbed my chocolate milkshake and
went back to Ecolab I'm going back to
work man this is my life
so in this job you look you know you're
looking for cockroach she's looking for
rodents and stuff like that and this
next morning or this next night I went
to work and I hit the all-night
cockroaches too much I hit the mother
lode of cockroaches and this restaurant
got full of cockroaches and rodents and
everything else and I sat there and said
this is my life I said this is my life
you are exactly who the [ __ ] that this
is it and I said this ain't gonna be it
for me so in that restaurant I quit my
job left my canister in that restaurant
my spray canister got back in my ecolab
truck and I went home and I started
working out like somebody I was I became
the most obsessed person on the planet
Earth that was basically I had to invent
a guy that didn't exist I had to invent
a guy that can take any pain any
suffering any kind of judgment be called
[ __ ] be called whatever the [ __ ] in
the world and be understanding the
[ __ ] room and said go [ __ ] yourself I
had it built the I had to build this
callous mind and I built it to suffering
I built it to downright [ __ ] just
crushing myself if it was raining
outside three o'clock in the [ __ ]
morning feeling the first instinct is
don't go out there and do [ __ ] my
instinct was we gotta [ __ ] go out
there anything that was [ __ ] horrible
in my life that I would normally say no
that was inhumane that most people I had
to go do it and I started callous in my
mind at this point in my life and I lost
the weight I lost the weight and I went
back to recruiter I got into that class
and I went through three Navy sohail
weeks in one year only God ever be in
three hell weeks in one year after my
knowledge the first one I didn't make it
through the next two I did and that I
just didn't stop anymore from there
and I started realizing through this
through this process that the [ __ ]
mind is what you created and I started
opening different doors that I didn't
think we're even there they didn't think
even existed and the more doors are
opening up the more I start realizing
that my potential is damn near endless
and it changed my whole mindset so I
went from David Goggins and I created
Goggins and that journey is a priceless
journey that is hard for me to explain
to people because it sounds so quick and
easy that guy's lost this weight and I
went through three healthiest I went to
Ranger school went to Delta Force Lexus
whatever it is it was brutal it's a
brutal journey every [ __ ] day and if
ever less what are you happy
if anybody knows my life story and I try
to give you a just a snippet of it where
I'm at two days in front of Joe Rogan
telling you my life to get through what
I became to get to where I'm at now
there's nothing but pride I have for
myself that I can't really I can't
really show people because I have this
face and a space that they see like are
you happy what's wrong with you I'm
driven I'm obsessed and that's what you
see that's it people need to hear this
story
this is a this is an exciting story for
people because there's a lot of people
out there that feel trapped and they
feel stuck and they feel like they can't
do anything this is who they are you're
a guy who felt that exact same way but
figured out how to not be that person
and be a person
you would admire how did you what were
the first steps like you had some slips
before right because you you quit
because of the water thing right but
then when you went back the second time
and you decide you're going to lose all
that weight and you quit that job did
did you was it just straight forward
from there or whether there's some days
where you just failed and then you
picked it back up again so my first run
when I decided to lose the weight I was
like I said 297 I was about thirty two
percent body fat and I went my idea was
to run four miles for my first run I
didn't know how bad it's gonna [ __ ]
hurt me I used to run before I was fat
and I was like [ __ ] it I can do this I
ran a quarter mile and walked home I
walked home and sat on my couch and
cried I miss my mom's house who was
about 40 about maybe 20 minutes down the
road and cried and getting her couch
saying I can't [ __ ] do this I don't
know what I'm gonna do I just got
somebody pregnant my life was this
[ __ ] I was making $1,000 a month my
rent was 8/10 a month and my mind just
kept [ __ ] with me and kept [ __ ]
you're not good enough man this isn't
for you man these guys are best mother
[ __ ] on the planet Earth you not that
and what it was and it's kind of funny I
was obsessed with rocky rocky one in
particular and when I was a kid I come
home every day and I watched his [ __ ]
show rocky and I was fast forward with
the little VHS tapes to round 14 round
14 [ __ ] me up like nobody's business
why this song came on right so when I
bought the pull-up record I listened to
the song for 17 hours it's two minutes
and 13 seconds and I'm able to visualize
and dream like nobody's business and I
know that I can create a vision that
many people can't and I work for it so
the vision I had was when Apollo Creed
beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of Rocky beat
the [ __ ] out of him he's kept fighting
he was a dumb fighter couldn't read
couldn't [ __ ] on me couldn't read
couldn't write just punchy everything
about him and rocky beaches are probably
[ __ ] using that corner everybody was
saying stay the [ __ ] down
and him getting up him getting up Apollo
Creed raised his arms up in the [ __ ]
air turn around thought he won the fight
he turns around and sees this guy
getting up and it was the face of Apollo
Creed that changed my life the face of
Apollo Creed it was like just by that
[ __ ] getting up not winning just
by him getting the [ __ ] up Apollo Creed
was his champ his best rocky had taken
his soul had literally taken his soul
his his head goes down he looks down
like Ruth what the [ __ ] are you
I wanted to be that not Rocky I want to
be the guy that people looked at I don't
keep you've liked me or didn't like I
don't care but said this [ __ ] is
gonna keep coming after whatever the
[ __ ] is in front of them I wanted that I
wanted that I wanted that worse than
anything in the world
so that is I kept picturing me falling
down and getting up and every
[ __ ] that called me [ __ ] I was
dumped even myself even myself I wanted
to feel something besides two feet I
wanted to just go to distance and that
going a distance pushed me to a point of
where now I go way past the distance so
you go the first day you run a
quarter-mile and you walk back home and
you're you're upset how do you how do
you move forward so basically idea was I
came home and I had a talking milkshake
I sat down and I gave up I said it
saying go [ __ ] happen Mac I lose 106
pounds and I came and go a quarter a
[ __ ] mile I started being able to
take negative [ __ ] and be happy and this
whole I say what if a lot it sounds
corny and it sounds weak but it's true
one of the recruiters said there's not
many black Navy SEALs in fact I was a
thirty six african-american seal in
history
is in overseas because the [ __ ] water
you know I mean people get mad at me
it's [ __ ] true just get over it and
so I was like man what story would it be
if my [ __ ] fat dumb lying to be
people insecure ass can overcome this
[ __ ] and that would if mentality like
that that dreamer mentality just would
always fuel me it was just ruin man what
if I can be but if I can be a seal man
what if I can go from wearing a quarter
of [ __ ] mile now I run 205 miles what
if I can go but just what if I can go in
and what if how would that feel if I'm
graduating kind of get at that
graduation thing I was talking about
224th like the video I said then I'll
watch this command officer stood up and
he said to the graduation guys you're
graduating buds like eighteen of them he
said we live in a society where
mediocrities often rewarded and we don't
to say something about these men detest
mediocrity and I wanted to be a man that
the test mediocrity you know it got me a
lot of trouble in the SEAL Teams and
going forward in my life because I just
I started looking down on people for not
going hardest [ __ ] [ __ ] and I started
to create different things but that's
for a different day but I just believe
that it you know my whole mind changed
that is a problem that a lot of people
who work hard to have you get angry at
people who don't work hard to the point
where you you know you want to insult
them you want to you want to smack them
and it's really because you're scared of
seeing that yourself yeah that's
probably the truth that's probably the
truth so I guess a lot of times my life
I would see people and it part was a
direct reflection of who I was and I
would get mad at them but reflections
probably just be getting mad at myself
yeah that's for me 100% when I when I
see people they're half-ass some things
I get terrified of seeing that in myself
and I get mad at them right and it's uh
it's not a good way to handle it no you
know but it's it's natural because
you're just terrified of seeing that
trait right and it cost me so you come
back mmm you do the quarter-mile right
you walk back home how do you regroup so
what I did I sat down then I put rocky
in I got my milkshake put rocky ice you
know what I was big-time in Rocky and
platoon why platoon I love to see people
who were getting beat down and this
there's there's scenes there's scenes
that this drove me and people in my hell
weeks you know I was in three of them
always hear me singing these songs these
songs humming these songs in torturous
situations when you're when everybody's
quitting this [ __ ] code I would be
somewhere gone somewhere [ __ ] gone if
somewhere [ __ ] darkest [ __ ] there's a
scene of platoon when Elias Wimborne and
shoots Elias and you know they think
Elias is dead and the choppers are
taking off and charlie sheen's ask him
you know Tom Berenger
where's Elias reason lies Willem Dafoe I
found him back there dead somewhere and
through the woods the Viet Cong has
chasing he lies through the woods and
the shoot him in his [ __ ] back
and all he wants to do is get to the
[ __ ] chopper he's getting shot in his
back he's getting up getting something
face getting up and you see this guy
just fighting
I love the [ __ ] guy who just [ __ ]
fights and so I put these things in as
reminders that you're gonna have to
[ __ ] suffer man this [ __ ] point
two-five man this is man you're gonna
have to [ __ ] suffer to go from this
fat insecure [ __ ] to one of the
best guys on the planet Earth this
journeys could take something that is
going to be incomprehensible to most
people and these different
visualizations how I visualized myself
talked it became so nasty and dirty that
I wasn't liked the fact that I went
point to five so it became from being
defeated to like man all right
[ __ ] maybe you know maybe
tomorrow and go point seven-five you
know it just became this different
mindset I turn negatives into positives
so I would I would take it like who
would even think about doing this so I
would sit in my couch saying who at 297
who can't [ __ ] swim that great who
scary the [ __ ] water we have the
[ __ ] balls kind of balls to [ __ ]
man up quit a job and go and it put
everything on himself
so it's how I started talking to myself
and put myself in a whole different
category and that was fueling me the
next day and I just kept using that as
fuel and fuel no one would do this [ __ ]
no one do this [ __ ] you're the best
[ __ ] around you're the best
[ __ ] ever live and I had the
guys kept fueling me with them with the
right kind of message that I needed to
hear that was never telling myself and
through time
became reality to myself so you start
out on the first day and then do you
start running again the second day yeah
the second day was right back after
again but I start realizing I can't run
that for right so what I did was I
became damn near a professional cyclist
with the miles I put it on the bike so I
never we never watched TV
I had to be doing something so I was
riding the bike I rode a bike a lot to
lose the first initial kind of weight
cuz it took my bones were just hurting
so bad my bow is broken and I learned to
get over that also and I tried to swim a
lot I weren't a great swimmer but
putting fins on kind of equalized my
body I wasn't so negative buoyant so I
started fitting a whole bunch and I
spent hours in the pool hours in the
pool trying to get more and more
comfortable not because I was going
underwater I was so scared of the water
that I had to live in the water I had to
become one with the water so going to
the pool used to scare me so I went to
the pool an awful awful lot and then the
bike got easier I was able to run more I
went from like one mile one mile was a
great accomplishment two miles and then
from 2 to 3 was a big one I went from 3
to 6 and then like they have a warning
order that they give people to get ready
for buts and the whole thing was running
6 miles five days a week and that was my
goal and so I just kept I failed I go
back to scratch I use some positive
motivation I have like one day where I
like [ __ ] defeated but I started
realizing this a part of the process
this is a part of the journey I had to
realize this is part of my process
versus just saying like I used to
I'm just not good enough if I'm not good
enough we always say that [ __ ] that's
not good enough and then we try
something else
I'm gonna [ __ ] make myself good
enough and that became my mentality I'm
gonna make myself good enough and so I
misunderstood a lot but that's that's
all it came down to I made myself good
enough and the days I couldn't run that
far the next week I would do two a days
so on the running if I ran a
quarter-mile I weighed a [ __ ] couple
hours it haunt me bother me I try to run
a half a mile next time same day you can
do more than this if I had to walk ahead
and walk it just became just a process
of
grinding and grinding and grandees not
even a good word for it it's not even a
good word for it and just just going
further and further and then when I got
through running I go to the bike I go to
the pool if I got tired somewhere my
legs are tired
I go to the gym and I develop this crazy
workout where I was doing volume like
two-three hundred reps of like very
lightweight people I said how you know
how come you have any like loose skin my
workout routine the gym became sick it
became sick I was just doing two three
hundred reps four hundred reps on like
chest just like for one simple exercise
the best press and a racket get back on
it just rep it out trying to burn as
many calories I can't build that muscle
mass and ice became just became obsessed
with it so when you're doing this are
you worried at all about repetitive
stress injuries or the fact that your
body's not conditioned for this and
you're basically taking your body where
you had abused it right and now you're
you're forcing it to live like in an
elite athlete right I didn't care I
didn't know any better I didn't think
about it wow I didn't I didn't know that
working out that hard would [ __ ] you up
I did it [ __ ] you up oh yeah yeah that's
one reason I'm with you three Hill weeks
so I don't talk about a lot but um the
stress of my life getting to 24 calls me
have some serious so as issues I know
anything about this [ __ ] there's so as
muscles what we use history hip flexor
muscle and basically under stress it
starts to tighten up and I was I started
for from the time I was in third grade
time I was in seventh grade white
blotches on my skin I was just I was in
that case and so the insides of me are
also getting [ __ ] up so in this
process my soul has mostly got real
tight to my t12 I can show you the bump
on the back of my head after this show
is over but I had I started growing this
[ __ ] like large tumor or looking bump
on the back of my head from my body
compressing so I'm six foot one but my
muscles were like five foot nine because
I just started just the muscle tightness
for my so ass going to my t12 I was just
getting tighter my quads everything
getting tired from just stress just
stress in my life so the more I stressed
my body with the workouts
my lower body became out of balance so I
had a bunch of stress fractures bunch of
injuries going through buds and how I
got through buds was they gave me my
third time was my last time going
through hell week I basically put a
black sock on at four o'clock in the
morning and I would get duct-taped I had
a numerous stress fractures on both of
my legs because my my body was literally
like coming in on itself in my legs like
I was I was pronating it really bad and
putting stress on my stress on my shins
and so I would put duct tape I would
duct tape my feet and I would show you
the top of them where I have pressure
ulcers they're the size of quarters from
you know how the ankle joint so the foot
goes to the shin and how you move this
where the tape was so tight it just
created a nice ulcer right there and I
just uh just kept going through it so
you just use that tape to just support
your ankles right so I basically cast
myself and for the first 30 45 minutes
the pain was excruciating but then it
would go numb and I would go numb and
then I saw I got through Wow did that do
any long-term damage oh yeah I've been
out for five years so I retired from the
I did 21 years in military this time in
the Air Force and I did about 16 years
in the Navy how old you 43 she looks
like you're 30 that's good that's good
you really you look very young for your
age whenever I'm stressed I get after it
I think I fixed was ever bothering me so
I basically over the last five years
everything I've done in my life I did it
be very unhealthy I've never talked
about it I just kept going and it cost
me pretty much I was choking my insides
out adrenal issues tons of general
issues thyroid issues anything with the
endocrine system pretty much shut down
on me a lot my organs were pretty much
shutting down and I went from a guy who
could run 205 miles to a guy who
couldn't get a bed and the doctors were
trying to search what was wrong that's
why I figure out the psoas muscle no one
figured it out and I hit it by accident
so I I've missed two days of stretching
out in five years and so what happened
was all this should I did to myself this
dress I
under physical mental all kind of [ __ ]
it just choked me out from the inside
and doctors put me all kind of
medication and the medication started
doing the exact opposite it was kind of
sure I was on um DHEA I was on some
different things for my estrogen
different things for my I was on
anything to do with your with your
endocrine system thyroid medicine get
God I was on quarters all kind of [ __ ]
to get my stuff I'd like just lump in my
throat from like the heart was always I
couldn't run down the street my body was
just jacked up couldn't sleep my hope I
was just down shutting down I could give
you a lot more than that but just give
me example I was [ __ ] dying and so I
couldn't do anything I went from a guy
who was this guy to a guy who can't do
[ __ ] and doctors like I don't know
what's wrong with you me you know your
labs or this is it PTSD is it what's
going on I knew what any of that [ __ ] so
I sat in the bed one day and I realized
man my life is over this is it but it
gave me time to reflect on everything
I'd accomplished I've never taken time
to reflect on the kid I was to the man I
am now so honestly the time I wasn't
working out it was the best time I live
because I got a chance to really reflect
back and be proud of who I became guy
never took time to do that it was like
one after another get the [ __ ] after get
after it get after you ain't good
nothing my [ __ ] get after it get after
it and I'm I got halted so anyway this
process went on for a while more
medication this isn't working that's not
working no doctor can figure it out I'm
like [ __ ] it I saw this doc about eight
years before this happened he was like
hey man you're so [ __ ] tight I've
never seen anybody in my life as tight
as you you need 50,000 hours of
stretching he's doing some crazy number
I like whatever stretching the you know
it stretch stress is bad for you so you
thought stretch was but that's just bad
for you why did you think that I read
some article you know a man [ __ ] [ __ ]
stretching man I worked out so hard I
don't have time to stress man I was 150
miles a week I was biking to work man I
was getting after it man I was working a
full-time job
and stretching and doing that so my body
was literally getting tired and tired
not just from what I was doing but
there's all cuz you ran this nut wasn't
that man and so I said no I'm gonna try
to stretch out so I don't do anything
for like ten minutes
or you know I don't do to a six-minute
abs [ __ ] so I start stretching out
one hour hour and a half long story
short man I shaved my head unless every
morning and that bump doesn't the back
of my [ __ ] head I started realizing
it was shrinking for some [ __ ] reason
I don't know why because I shaved my
head back and I was like it's getting
smaller smaller that bump got healthier
I got smaller that bump got I was like
oh hold up [ __ ] what's going on
that so whereas muscle started getting
more and more stressed out more more
relaxed and over a period of five years
I'm the best shape in my damn life right
now from stretching out Wow that's all
it was I went from like I came in
counting medications I was on now I'm on
a very low dose thyroid pill period do
you ever do yoga all the time man all
the time and I if I were to tell
somebody one thing right now man that's
so as muscle and getting that hip flexor
opened up because we're all stressed the
[ __ ] out it was it's almost worse than
others it changed my life yeah how do
you say Nick Gregorius how do you say
his last name
the Brazilian jiu-jitsu black belt from
England the Greek fella he has a great
quote about yoga he said yoga is a
martial art you do against yourself yep
it's a great way of putting it a hundred
percent so what it feels like when
you're in there right hundred percent
and so you how many years ago was this
it was five years ago anything and how
long was there a period where you
couldn't work out at all there was about
so I always try to do something but I
couldn't run hardly though I could run
maybe half a mile and all that hard [ __ ]
would happen in my heart would get a fit
and I'll cast off what happened and I
started just stretching and also I tried
to pull ups every now and then but
everything was just I didn't have the
energy I didn't have anything I mean
nothing was processing right for me so
do you think that you just broke in your
body you pushed it too hard hundred
percent
sat back in that bed that night and I
had a lot of time to reflect us you know
what I was actually kind of proud of
myself in a very sick twisted way I even
though people would understand it I had
to do what I had to do and you know and
I did it like I didn't tell you how I
got into ultrarunning
you know there's a lot of things that so
I I pushed extremely hard I went way
beyond what I thought was capable like
my first ultra race I did I was uh I was
heavier I was in Iraq you know the
marcus luttrell lone survivor I was in
buds I was in three hell weeks as you
know as I said many times and I knew a
lot of guys that died in the operation
now I was at freefall school with
marking the trail who is his twin
brother during the operation wet wings
wear market rosin on a survivor
I knew market real well and I was about
200 some odd pounds and I didn't run
hardly at all at this time I was a seal
but I was like a bodybuilder
and I did it elliptical trainer 20
minutes on Sunday all I did so I did
[ __ ] that cardio stuff I was never about
it until this happened so that happened
and I was like man I gotta find a way to
raise money for these families so I
googled the I I found a foundation the
Special Operations Warrior Foundation
and I googled the 10 hardest races in
the world I knew nothing about ultra
running the first I'd ever run was 20
miles at one time and so what came up
was the bad water 135 135 mile run
through Death Valley in the summertime I
thought was a [ __ ] stage race I know
people can run her 35 miles at one time
had no idea was imminent stage race
would you run like 20 miles I'll camp
out and then run 20 more to get her 35
miles right so I wouldn't alter runner
to know ultra runner was I called the
race director up Chris Kaufman of the
bad water spinning he said are you an
ultra runner and I was like I don't know
what that is
he goes have you run 100 miles in 24
hours or less I was like no but I said
I'm a Navy SEAL I was in 3 Heloise I was
arranged I gave him some resume he
didn't give a [ __ ] he said I don't care
you got qualified for my race and the
deadline was up in two months for this
bad water race and basically he said
there's two more races you can do to
qualify
and I might consider you my race we
select top 90 athletes in the world and
you know even all true runner but I like
your cause like what you're doing he
said uh I come up on a Wednesday and he
goes there's a race on Saturday in San
Diego San Diego one day when you run
around a one-mile track for 24 hours
Samiha miles you get if you get 100 24
hours I will consider you in my race I
did the math 14 some minute mile [ __ ] it
I can do that dumb [ __ ] thinking I'll
tell you that right now
it was rough worst pain I've been in my
entire life or this race so I have my
wife that time she's not my ex-wife we
go to Walmart get a blue lawn chair Ritz
crackers in my licks that's what I'm
gonna have for a hundred mile run
so show up at the start line this race
it was a you a national championships
it's like the best ultra runners compete
against each other to Sydney miles you
can get in 24 hours and I'm this big
bodybuilder looking guy but there's do
it like them I would say I was at least
230 at least it may have been more than
jacked yeah oh yeah I was ripped to [ __ ]
up I'm a big ol chest out date I was I
was jacked up there's a picture I mean
he definitely didn't look like someone
who could run a home run no not at all
so basically I start running and I get
to about mile 40 mile 50 and I'm feeling
pretty good I get to mile 70 and it was
the worst pain of my life i sat down
this blue lawn chair at Mile 70 and my
the rich crackers after mile 20 became
wrist cracker bong sky wasn't hydrating
correctly I don't know what to do I was
drinking mile Plex for my nutrition
because I couldn't eat these rich
crackers have very minimal water if any
at all and I was just dying so I sat
down this blue lawn chair as I was
watching lies runners go around in this
circle and I was all dizzy and
lightheaded hadn't gone in the bathroom
it's been about 12 hours I went 70 miles
about 12 hours which is good and I
looked at my ex-wife now and I was like
I am [ __ ] I started seeing like three
of her and once my body stopped my mind
just went off and I had to go to the
bathroom and the bathroom is like it's
like 20 feet away from me if that not
Cooney
and so I sat there and pee blood down my
leg and start crapping up my back and
for 30 miles to go I am my feet were
broken I was just in the worst shape
because once you stopped running not
running like that I mean I didn't run in
almost a year I was just doing body
building stuff and 20 minutes on the
elliptical trainer no running at all I
probably ran no [ __ ] no [ __ ] no more
than 50 miles the whole year that wasn't
my thing I want it to be like jacked you
know I didn't want to be cardio guy I
want to be ripped big Navy SEAL guy and
um in the day before this race is funny
this guy named Joe Burns who put me
through my hell weeks a SIL guy he's one
of the hardest guys out there he was in
the gym the Friday before I did this
race and he was doing a full body squats
deadlifts power cleans I get my own you
know he he's a guy that proved me to do
this race you know he gave me the
approval to go do this race and signed
off on it so I'm in the gym I went in
there did a full-body hardcore squats
deadlifts and everything with this guy
because I knew he was gonna come watch
me in this race so I've always been
about all right man you're gonna see me
coming here and Jack this weight and the
more you watch me do a hundred mile run
we can think about that so basically I
paid for it so at my so he came out
there with my favorite thing chocolate
you know mini doughnuts because he knew
my story of my past life and brought the
six minute doughnuts out there and I'll
have my hat pulled down and at Mile 70
men it was torturous and with blood down
my leg and 30 miles to go I started
reaching the cookie jars man I started
pulling off all kind of stuff I reached
in my mind and a lot of us when we have
bad times in life even the hardest
person where we forget how badass we are
during that hard time I have a thing
where I take a couple seconds to reflect
on I hang on man you've meant to been
through this you've been through that
you overcame this overcame that I don't
ever close my mind to the fact that this
can't be done
and I knew I had to get up I need
nutrition I need hydration I need to get
stop being dizzy so that's the first
thing I did I didn't panic gonna have 30
more miles to go to get
I start about the process slowly but
surely I was able to stand up and I was
literally hobbling around this track
we're just walking no running at all I
couldn't run my feet were in the worst
pain it's the worst pain I've been in my
entire life nothing in any training is
even a comparable to this last 30 miles
and what happened was my ex-wife looked
at me and she's like man you're this we
agreed I'm not gonna make the time I was
going way too slow
and at that time at mile 81 something
clicked that I'll never probably be able
to do again where my mind body spirit
soul everything disconnected and my mind
knew I wasn't [ __ ] around anymore it
knew it wasn't gonna quit it knew that
guy was dead and buried and gone and I
was gonna die out here on this [ __ ]
Walmart for whatever reason why I was
gonna get through this [ __ ] I
didn't give a damn it made no there was
no [ __ ] crowds there was no trophy at
the end there was I wasn't even in a
race in my mind there was it was nothing
it weren't about nothing there was no
nothing it was a bunch of people who
didn't know who the [ __ ] I was it was me
against me and I used all these
different dark places to start bringing
out light and just [ __ ] going deeper
and deeper in it running the next 20
miles around 101 miles and I ran the
next 20 miles ran at about a 1030 pace
and I did 101 miles in 18 hours and 56
minutes sat back down that blue
port-a-potty now my chair that got from
Walmart and that's when the body
realized I was done and this great
feeling came over me but also the worst
pain in my life I that's when I took a
humongous [ __ ] on myself literally like
I like a [ __ ] log up my [ __ ] back
piss so much blood down and my wife was
she was a nurse and she was freaked out
I couldn't get up I couldn't stand up
she backed this Camry on the knoll of
the grassy area I was at and we were
both lifters at the time so she was
decently strong I put my arms around her
neck she got me to the backseat of the
car that the windows down cos smelled
like horrible [ __ ] and I had this poncho
line because November in San Diego so
I'm sitting there Jack him in the back
his car and she was terrified anything
dr. Anita
that's take me home so we look in the
second story or the second deck of this
apartment complex in San Diego I got to
the first deck so I get a car and I
could stand up but with my arms on her
neck so just leaning down I was gonna
pass out got to the second or I got to
the first deck went down just couldn't
stand up anymore got around her neck
worked up my way up the railing
gamma-gamma I was on her neck again
walked to the kitchen area which is
right in the front door I was laying on
a poncho liner crap was everywhere
I managed she helped me manage to get
into the toilet into the tub and it's
like dirt was coming on my penis
this looked horrible just just that
grossly in the world it was worst pain I
can ever ever ever be in in my life and
the craziest thing I tell your story
because it's right now I'm not sadistic
I'm not crazy people may think that any
way they may want to put a title on me
after hearing me because it makes them
feel better because they think wow this
guy must be some special or just [ __ ]
up crazy dude no I'm a guy that came
from nothing anybody's capable of doing
[ __ ] like this anybody and I sat in that
tub she's put the water on me she called
my mom up and my mom was dating a doctor
at the time the doctor he actually said
you need to get him to a hospital now
she came back in all I want to do is
call Chris Koster on the phone the race
director of bad waters I [ __ ] did it
so she some taken to doctor I said no
let me sit here enjoy this pain she said
what are you talking about I said you
don't I go I need to go to the doctor I
realize that but I never thought it was
humanly possible to do what I did I went
70 miles in at 70 miles I was dead I was
at a hundred percent what I thought what
I thought was 100%
I went 30 I went 31 more miles after
being in the worst physical shape I've
ever been in in my life and all that all
that pain and suffering and thing was
going through my [ __ ] body and I sat
in that tub and the waters hitting me it
was the most amazing feeling of
accomplishment and I want to be numb I
want people to give me drugs and
numbness [ __ ] pain I wanted to I did
this however as crazy as it sounds it
was the most amazing moment of my entire
life to overcome such to come from this
kid who was mentally torturing something
was torture is talk to this kid - Skyy
now who was able to overcome such
amazing odds and obstacles and I called
Chris cost him up the race director of
bad water and he said the idea of a
24-hour race is to run 24 hours you
really ran 19 and he put doubt in my
mind that he was that mean - bad water
so a month later or so about a month and
half later I went this race called the
hurt 100 so hundred mile race in Hawaii
26,000 feet of climb was all he said
that's all he said that's so crazy I
mean he's a hardcore dude but he didn't
know how [ __ ] up I was right and he
said he didn't say well you know I can't
say no I might let you win
he put enough doubt in my mind and say
man I got to do more so I was broken I
was broken bad and like how long does it
take you to recover physically the
funniest thing about this I'll tell a
story very often I had signed up for I'm
getting to that answer it's right now
I'm in deployment and me and my wife my
mom signed up for the first Las Vegas
Marathon down the strip of Las Vegas and
that isn't happened
so I ran 100 miles before I ran a
marathon
two weeks later roughly December 5th was
this marathon that we all signed up for
I couldn't walk I could not walk I was
[ __ ] up so it's ten days or two weeks
after this 100 mile in one race I did
this marathon December 5th Las Vegas I
said you know it's the first one I can't
run maybe I can walk with my mom so I
tried to go out this little Knoll around
our grassy area in San Diego I tried to
run legs were broken I said [ __ ] I can't
even I'm jacked can't do [ __ ] so I said
you know what maybe I'll watch you guys
do the marathon and I'll cheer you guys
on whatever I said I'll try walk with my
mom December 5th happened that gun went
off 2005
14 days after I broke myself off and I
qualified for the Boston Marathon around
308 that's crazy and what's funny about
I know people here says [ __ ]
even when I tell you the story I dropped
I want to drop so many names google it
look it up I don't give a [ __ ] like
almost seems like I'm making my own
story up it does it almost seems like it
to you it does I cannot tell it if I
were to hear somebody I said let's you
know just do you Joe Rogan's podcast I
heard some black dude from [ __ ]
Brazilian hand talking about I this
happened this happened three weeks
Ranger school ran a hundred miles broke
my feet broke my body I'm like this man
he's the biggest [ __ ] liar on the
planet or ain't nobody know [ __ ] even
why I tell my story it almost sounds
like some made-up [ __ ] so yes crazies
you ran a hundred miles before you ever
ran a marathon right then you didn't run
again at all and he's still qualified
for the Boston Marathon so you ran a 308
right for the first marathon you ever
did ever did two weeks after you ran a
hundred miles right with no training and
nothing in between but it gets better
than that you can see my training log to
actually post it up so that's when I
started training for the hurt 100 so
basically what happened was after that I
had about four weeks what did it feel
like to run that 308 if you could barely
walk when that gun went off something
went off in my head and I didn't feel
that much pain at all afterwards I did
but something happened where I was like
the gun went off and that thing came
back like all right man what if because
I want to qualify for Boston that was my
goal but I was I was jacked up you know
and I and I and I didn't run as much
that sort of at all over my Iraq
training I hit the weights and but my
job but but my goal was my son that
forward a year early
I want to qualify for Boston which was a
three 10:59 and I was like what if you
can qualify for Boston mayor and so we
wit helped me out I spent 101 miles
what the [ __ ] is 26 miles to me now so
the mindset going into it was like I ran
75 more miles in this so I use it to my
advantage so after that happened I ran
but my feet pretty much broken I would
go to the physical therapist and they
had this compression tape compressing
tape help because I'm my feet were
pretty bad off and I would run 7080
hundred mile weeks and then I went to
the hurt 100 race in Hawaii 26,000 feet
of climbing over 100 miles probably one
of the top five hardest hundred mile
races in the world
I wouldn't even a real runner yeah I
baked a lot of miles by the last the
last but two and a half about two months
but I want a runner went out there and
got through the race did in 33 hours
with a ninth place finisher
not many people finished that that year
and I qualified for bad water and got in
and I went on to lose weight and train
hard and I got fifth my first year I
went back my second year and got there
when you say you went you lost weight
like what were you eventually way in so
I went to the race about 190 we lost
quite a bit yeah bodybuilding time right
that's over a short period of time right
how did you lose all that way once again
I I just worked out hard I stopped
taking my protein so much I got off I
was on this stuff called a nitro tech
and I got off all the protein stuff I
started I stopped hitting the weights so
hard and I just became a running fool
became the Black Forest got man pretty
much pretty simple man that's what
happened now when you say you were using
compression tape on your feet and that
your feet were jacked up what was the
extent of the injuries so basically
because of my pronation that I never
figured out cuz my soul has muscles I
always had issues with stretch fractures
shin splints so I put a lot of pressure
on the inside of my ankles and so that
there's this tendon that goes up the
backside of your I don't know if it's
your fibula my backside that of that
little bone backs out your foot it goes
right up beside that lot right alongside
that bone and that thing was just so
fluid up on both sides that even this
flexing my foot was just killing me so I
when you can you know when you cast that
thing up casting my feet always helped
me out because it it it locked my foot
into a position that wouldn't made me
pronate as much so between the casting
of that and if you watched the a bad
water video of 2006 you see me crossing
the finish line with this compression
tape literally like flying on my ankles
because I went to the race with
compression tape on my ankles and so
basically I'd have that on my you know
on my ankles I had inserts in my you
know in my shoes and also this wedge on
the back heel of my left foot so then it
would keep me from pronating that heel
so much so I had all that on just to go
around
and I ran my ass off and went to bad
water 2006 and with compression tape on
my feet and walked a lot but I got third
place do you always run with regular
running shoes I do yeah so now I don't
have those issues anymore all the
stretching has opened my body up to
where I know how it should have been so
my alignment is pretty good it's not
perfect so now I just run in regular
running shoes now no no more compression
tape no more none that stuff so if you
see now if you look down there you'll
see they can press it up and you'll see
my ex-wife here in a second taking their
compression tape off of me she's doing
it right now
you see her right now you know she said
tape yeah so that's the tape I didn't
have to wear every day of my life to run
Wow so as you see the story may be kind
of unbelievable but there's some proof
right there so that's how I was so
painful yeah I was pretty [ __ ] up as
you see right now me trying to get all
man yeah I'm pretty destroyed right
there what is the most amount of miles
you've ever run at one time yeah two
hundred and five and thirty nine hours
Wow non-stop whoo yeah I've had quite a
few people on I've met quite a few
people now over the last year so that
have run ultras Courtney doe Walter you
know she is she won the Moab okay yeah I
heard my 40 rather heard about yes she
she beat all the men by 22 miles
something like that some crazy things
she was first place winner she beat
everybody else
second place one word
and with her I mean you would never
believe it wouldn't talk to her she
seemed so normal right she drinks beer
and eats nachos needs candy ultrarunner
man she's just silly and she's fun
yep and there's no demon there I like
waiting to meet a demon right you know
I'm like where's your demon like how are
you getting through her demons a quiet
demon right it's it's there it has to be
okay there's something there has to be
there's no other people that everybody I
know that that can do that as a demon a
lot of us don't want admit to [ __ ] yeah
we got him a hundred percent it has to
be yeah so when you do this and you you
qualify and you do that race in Hawaii
right they just let you in after that no
so the race in Hawaii yeah I actually
called the race jerk threw up and there
wasn't like a big time like I had to
have 100-mile race I believe as I had
and so you know 100-mile you did the
boss of merit or you did the Vegas
marathon yeah so I did a hundred mile
101 miles the Vegas marathon went to
hurt 100 did that hundred mile ER and
all this is in a very short amount of
time yeah so November was the first time
jamala December was the 26 mile or not
in Las Vegas January was the next
hundred miles on Hawaii you know [ __ ]
crazy that is like say if I was your
friend and I called you up on October
20th I go hey man how many times you run
like run every night I see something
crazy I'm gonna pull it up or not but if
you can pull my race schedule for 2007
this pull up David Goggins race results
you can see something real crazy in a
second they saying this is good and I
gotta show you proof because why I know
my story doesn't make any sense but this
look at the dates of these races and
we're gonna show it to you in a second
it's um just look at the hundred miles
and 15 hours back-to-back weekends how
many weekends there were between races
so if you look right here you can't
really see it so he's look at 2007 yeah
go all the way down keep on going 2007
steals races there and do that okay get
to right there so hundred mile or Hawaii
oh gee looked up first two weeks later
three weeks later another one that's
50-miler a 50-miler
a month later then looking at what 14
days later another 50k
50-miler month later they look at less
than a month
another 50-miler 53 milder in June July
was another 100 miler bad water was
literally reached that water was a month
after I did that hundred mile or 135
Marlette Ville was less than a month
after bad water the plane 100 was three
weeks after Leadville Angels crest was
to attend date a week after that energy
modeler the bare 100 was wet thirteen
days after that hundred mile or she and
then I ran the two hundred and it said
to her and three point five but I didn't
ran toward its 205 miles around there
but what's not in there was that
McNaughton race I did in two thousand or
fifty mile race I also did in two
thousand seven that wasn't lifted so
that was just my 2007 year that's insane
yeah so do you think that is what [ __ ]
your body up no no no because I I still
run the same mileage now well [ __ ] my
body up was hell week really oh yeah you
don't go through three hell weeks in one
year so I so what happened was when I
realized that my body is really jacked
up was I went I was a big-time squatter
loved squatting and I went through the
first hell week got messed up ii hope
you got all the way through then throw
hope we could got all the way through
and my third hell we could hit me that
guy died on Thursday and then that hell
weekend and I graduated pulmonary edema
it was a code name was John stop it code
is [ __ ] hell week the Pacific Oceans
never warm and it rained the whole time
the whole time is rain and he pretty
much just drown on his own fluid pretty
much we were in the pool doing some
evolution he sunk to the bottom his
temperature was hot he missed a lot of
hell week for getting pulled out for
different stuff he wouldn't go quit and
I'm heating up dying he'll week but um
yeah so anyway after hell week ended I
want to go back to the gym you know so
second phase happened I face like I can
get back in the gym so I jacking my
weight
I love jack and weight and I realized I
couldn't squat so I went from squatting
a lot to I couldn't even squat the bark
and my lower back was all [ __ ] up I
was like I don't know what's going on
it was cuz this this muscle so inhale
week your hip flexors are so and I went
through so many of them so fast
and so the hardest part of buds I went
through three times not not the healthy
part yes one the hardest parts but it
was the initial part of the where
everybody sees on TV the log PT to surf
torture the dad gone boats over your
head law all that [ __ ] I went through
that person three times in one year and
over a period of time my hip flexors got
so tight that is jacked me up it jacked
me up for my hip flexor so so always
being so cold and so stressed out and
everything led up to it
but this really was the part that I
noticed I could squat before hell week
or before my first time going to buds
after after buds I couldn't I couldn't
squat anymore do you just think it might
just be because your body was exhausted
no cuz I for 12 years so I would I would
go back and tough it out like like with
Joe burns he was squatting so I said
[ __ ] I almost caught with Joe burns but
I just couldn't squat cuz that that
muscle was attached here at t12 so what
was it doing - is it locking up it was
pulling and so it made my hips feel like
I couldn't sink my ass oh I couldn't
sink so his incredible pain and then
with the weight pushing me down and then
trying to push up the pain was just is
just too much so so this is all range of
motion is always in motion issues yeah
Wow that that's an important thing for
my friend cam Haynes who doesn't stretch
he's another friend of mine who runs
ultra races he ran that moab 240 he's
run the bigfoot 205 he's run a few of
those right um i know he's listening go
stretch dude yes support man it was
especially if you work in that hard
right if you're doing that much yeah
you're you're definitely locking up he
could barely touch his toes yeah that's
not a good thing that's not good no no
it comes back to hurt you inside pretty
soon now how flexible you now cuz I
would imagine you probably a [ __ ]
ballerina at this point because sad when
your brain I'm trying to get there I'm
trying to get there so I stretch every
night for at least two hours there's a
thing that people said that it always
pissed me off like because I'm pretty
flexible they said oh you're naturally
flexible people have a natural threshold
like
oh they don't like a doctor told me that
I go you don't know what you're talking
about I'm like you don't know what you
talk about cuz most people don't push
themselves past that pain that stretch
pain alright people want to put a title
on your mask
easy for them oh yes exactly natural
exactly now you don't work hard enough
[ __ ] yeah people built like
chimps aren't usually flexible right you
have to you have to force yourself to do
that's right and I know it because I had
a friend my friend Tom our dog nah he
was a football player Jack big fick dude
terrible flexibility was taking
Taekwondo with me
and over the course of a couple years I
saw that dude eventually develop a full
split there you go and he just did it
through his mind yes was everybody else
was done training that guy would be on
the mat constantly stretch and always
working out cuz he had built his body up
so strong through all those years of
squatting and lifting yeah that he just
you know he was all tense everything was
just like this super powerful right but
all like very tense that's why I stopped
you know that's why I never stretched
because I wanted that strength yeah yeah
you want that tight muscle but no I
don't think it is stupid yeah I think
you're not supposed to stretch before
you do big physical activities because I
think it does like weaken you somewhat
but I don't think being flexible overall
makes you weak or not at all yeah what
certainly doesn't from martial arts
because you need that flexibility to
have leg dexterity to be able to kick
right it's got to be fluid where it's
not tightened up by the restriction of
the motion of your body I get it it's
truth I just think people are for
whatever reason and I'm one of those
drone on too much about yoga I'm like
one of those vegans it's like you got to
do it man right he's trying
I get it knowing like a born-again
Christian or something I'm getting that
way now man that way now for anybody
does anything hard like you know if you
do anything like with weightlifting type
[ __ ] or martial arts type [ __ ] where
it's just everything's explosion its
lifting it's heavy
push push push right yoga just will
balance your [ __ ] out yeah well yeah
really well man and there's all these
people that resist it like there was
some article recently that it was
something along the lines of hot yoga is
just trendy nonsense
I've read that and then even in the
article it talked about that there might
be some benefits in terms of like the
strengthening your arteries and they
didn't even mention
heat-shock proteins is a study going on
right now I believe it's at Harvard one
of my friends was telling me about it
where they're they're trying to find the
benefits of 90 minute hot yoga classes
because they think it might mirror the
observed benefits of sauna which they
already know for a fact has big benefits
because of your body producing heat
shock proteins to deal with the heat
right that's why I put that sauna in
here man I go in that [ __ ] all the
time well no one can tell me doesn't
work that's big it's proof positive you
changed my life it wasn't a medication
or this or a dress it was stretching
yeah it was yoga stretching all that
stuff combined changed it well I just
think it balances out your body in those
static poses where you're just holding
the pose and it just it works you out in
a weird way
that one's a person you just don't get
lifting weights or hitting the bag or
anything out you're just not gonna get
that that kind of working out I can't
agree with you more it's so difficult
crazy get your ass off and [ __ ] and
you're like this is like the silent
struggle it's humbling nobody knows it's
like if you see like two doorways right
and one of them is like [ __ ] CT Ollie
Fletcher's [ __ ] super pump iron
addicts gym which is hard work and then
right next to it is the yoga studio
you're like well once you get done with
all that hard work you'll go over to
that yoga studio no there's two
different kinds of hard work going on
it's no joke two different kinds of hard
work yes sir so what do you do now in
terms of like you got over this five
years ago you're in this bad situation
when your body's not working right now
everything's working great again well I
had two heart surgeries also whoa yeah
so you know your heart so I had a hole
in it so you know you're not supposed to
have a hole in your heart and be a seal
and it reborn with it I was born with it
it went undetected and me pushing so
hard so around in 2009 I was trying to
first race across America and I just
couldn't go anymore another pitfall in
my life was the hole and I was pretty
much off active duty steel for three
years yeah you know I had two hearts for
them trying to fix it so the hole was
significantly large look how big that
they say it was as big as a quarter now
Mike Holly Hill is it big as a quarter
yeah that's
a pretty big hole in your heart because
they had to helix patches I'm like
that's impossible that the helix patches
they're in my heart so the two stents
what is a helix patch it is like a
little mesh very like what they do for
hernias like something maybe something
like that so they went through my
femoral artery and they placed this
patch but to go through your artery yeah
everything my femoral artery yeah
looking with a camera yeah whoa so what
no the cameras down through my throat
whoa and they put this catheter through
my femoral artery get went to my heart
they they went and they took this helix
patch they place it in there and then
they found out six months later that the
hole wasn't covered up enough yet
because always I mean in the huge patch
was very damn big so they put it go back
in there in 2010 how does the patch
adhere to your heart I guess your heart
heals around the patch so but how did
they stick it in place I I guess they
put it with the holes at uh-huh and then
it kind of like inflates oh wow the hole
is that and then that that thing goes in
there and then it kind of covers a hole
and in the heart so there's two things
in my heart right now that the heart
just kind of covered up whoa okay so
there you go Jamie's got an image of it
for us whoa so so it's attached to this
little probe right and then they put it
over the area where the injury is Wow
that's insane yeah atrial septum defect
if I had atrial septal defect so
basically everything I had done I then
got from medicine oh [ __ ] you do I'll be
done that's so crazy that they could do
that yeah so I was out for I was
off-duty for three years so I stuck I
was in a recruiting area for three years
trying to get back on active duty and
that was my life for three years so they
put that patch in yep and now your
heart's 100% 100%
it sounds percent Wow yeah that's
incredible yeah I was losing you know
blood and I was just I was a bad off
it's just amazing that you were able to
do all that with a hole in your heart
that's what the doctors were saying you
know because eight naw I was a seal so
when I went in and the doctor that found
the hole are like so they'd gave me EKGs
all this stuff once again
may you after I ran like 205 miles you
know Ryan made you're in great shape I'm
like man I just don't feel good like
walking up the stairs this making me
jacked up so the doctor doc Shrek he's
like you know gave me he can go to the
doctor get an echocardiogram so I'm in
there getting echocardiogram just
chilling out in there and the guys
talking to him he has his little wand in
my heart
we're bullshitting about stuff and he
when people get quiet [ __ ] not good
man so he's in there this has one of my
heart chilling out yeah man we doing
yeah you know what's going on now like
he says I'll be right back
he goes and gets a doctor doctor comes
in puts thing I'm a heart the doctor
gets another doctor now I'm just
freaking the [ __ ] out I'm like okay cuz
when it comes to your heart
that was a big deal so they come back in
they say hey we can stop the
echocardiogram I mean he talked you out
in the hallway you have a hole in your
heart and the guy didn't know that I was
he knew I was Navy god I don't think he
was a seal because not me black guys are
seals and he had a conversation about
you know we gotta fix this real quick I
said yeah I mean then I came up that I
was the seal he said man you could have
died jumping you could die diving you
could have died into all this stuff cuz
basically the hole in your heart if it
gets plugged with something like
anything like you know let's say you get
a bubble from diving or something like
that
you got died right so I I I call it luck
I call it look so I I got through two
surgeries they put me back on they give
you the first one yeah and when do they
realize that it's not done not good
enough so they take you back and you get
a bubble study a bubble test so it's so
they like literally send bubbles that
way safe bubbles that way to see if the
bubble goes through your heart so they
have this this echocardiogram again and
they hook you up I think to ID or
something like that and they throw these
bubbles through your heart and they see
if it goes through after six months when
I should've been healed up the bubble
went through so had to tell me then hey
we got a you know you're not you're not
good to go so
I had to take a year before I have
another surgery because because that
patch had to be completely completely
healed so they can go back in time you
knew you had a hole right so so then you
add a hole because of the heart surgery
probably all this time like when you're
waiting for it details you know you have
an extra hole yes I don't have a hole
yes
what were you allowed to do with your
body then well at that time they go you
know do how you feel comfortable and so
you know the hole is not going to kill
you right now but you can't die if you
can't jump you pretty much wouldn't
steal anymore so I was a recruiter for a
period of time so basically I was crazy
about that is before my second surgery I
was actually training for Delta Force I
was I wanted to go to Delta and I was
rucking ruck running a lot and before my
second truck running I mean you're
running with a package I pack on my back
with some weight on how heavy is the
pack 50 60 pounds and you run with that
on well you're supposed to hike or hump
like ruck hopping right I ran with it
because I was you know I that's what I
did right so the date of the day of the
day of heart surgery I did a ruck run
Jesus because I knew I was gonna be out
of commission for a while so [ __ ] it
matter get my last one in dude Jesus
Christ all I could do I have my training
launch after my second heart surgery all
I could do was walk so I became an ultra
Walker I walked my [ __ ] ass off and I
over a period of time it took a year for
that thing to heal up in the hill you
know my first bubble study after my
second heart surgery came back negative
or positive the bubble went through
again oh no and they're gonna crack me
open oh man over that period of time my
heart healed around that thing nicely
and I passed a second bubble test so the
first bubble test was how long after a
year it was so the first bubble test
after the first surgery was six months
and then you had to go through a full
six months after that variety heal then
you have the second heart surgery and
when does the bubble test fail after the
second heart surgery it was about six
months Jesus Christ and they said and
the doctor looked at me and said you
know I'm sorry to inform you maybe we
have to crack your chest open the next
time they're really getting there
and so I sat back thinking this could be
a third heart surgery and then that one
they said we have to wait for six months
to see if this thing's gonna close up
right yeah I came back thinking man I'm
about to get cracked the [ __ ] open and
that bubble got pinned up man Wow when
they go through maybe forced it through
with your mind
it may add something to visualize holy
[ __ ] man that is crazy yeah it's crazy
one on a ruck run with a hole in your
heart - well I did it for several years
I said [ __ ] it
keep on going man that's amazing now
after all said and done everything's
good now yeah everything's I mean I'm
sure supposed to pop up in my [ __ ]
ass not to do that you know everything's
good right now
I'm always waiting for the next thing to
pop up and I hang on the same way I was
attack it but yeah I said right now I'm
in the best shape my 43 years old just
turned 43 February 17th I am in the best
shape my life I'm not knocking on wood
because life [ __ ] it life comes at you
dude so right [ __ ] knocking on wood come
at me I mean I would think that you
would be a go-to guy for injuries yeah I
give anybody had a ball I've had them
all I found when you broke the world
record for chin-ups didn't you rip your
arm apart pull-ups yeah so if you pull
up the picture man there's a picture of
my hand you'll see I'll know what is it
pull ups are so pull ups are here hands
out hands out and chin ups our hands
right hands forward so I failed three
times before I finally got it the third
time and I the first time I ripped the
[ __ ] on my forearm and then the second
time you'll see there's a picture of my
hand and it it's a third-degree burn so
that's my hand oh Jesus man what in the
[ __ ] is going to look at you a bit by a
wolf
so what's funny about that as you see
that uh that doesn't create after one
pull-up so if you can imagine the pain
of because you know you have one contact
point that's it
mmm you like running you can overcome it
cuz it these big giant legs and right
it's different when you have these
little fragile
punk-ass hands touching the bar no
imagine four thousand thirty pull-ups
how many times you're coming
that bar coming off right now way 207
pounds at the time so I was I was a
bigger guy I'm like 195 or 185 now so I
was almost 22 pounds heavier so I was a
lot bigger than I am right there ma'am
you look pretty get that [ __ ] man
so you were doing it in sets of five
sets of five so as you see I have these
different people who are witnessing you
you have to have your your your number
there to make sure that you're you know
qualified for the Guinness Book of World
Record that's 1450 I have a long way to
govern another four thousand and fifteen
pull-ups to go hurt Jesus Christ so yeah
and how long did you do this over 24
hours it was seven so I brought it at 17
Wow and I was [ __ ] over it what did
it feel like in the last chin up
you know what actually here's a video
that we have and I was chasing this guy
named Steven Highland so this guy named
Steven Highland had the record and the
video is my last three pulls for broke
the record I'm talking so much [ __ ]
there's another [ __ ] I'm like hey
[ __ ] you thought was good get it
huh I told you [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
I'm coming after you I'm here now is
this me talking [ __ ] it's a cool video
but I felt um I felt nothing I was just
happy I have to do anymore
I just 67,000 pull-ups in nine months G
in training first record for 4000 and
the failures so I I did the first time
in September failed miserably on this
today shot the twenty five hundred and
eighty eight or something like that
film is me for millions of people two
months later November tried again failed
again two months later in January 19th I
finally [ __ ] got it so after I got it
wasn't like I'm happy it was like I
gotta do more [ __ ] pull-ups anymore
Roger that so it was I had a [ __ ]
check that [ __ ] but you were doing them
when I got here today you know why cuz
now it's a party dude I don't like doing
this we could get somebody knocks him
out you don't like doing them so you got
to do them that's my whole life
isn't it like someone someone gets drunk
on a certain whiskey like if they smell
it they'll get disgusted like like
Jagermeister or something like that they
smell it no oh right is that what it's
like with you chin ups
along with envelopes with a lot of a lot
of things yeah right now I'm like
running out like and people don't
believe it but you know I was I was a
big guy twice in my life so hence the
reason why I just don't like running man
it hurts it's brutal it sucks going out
and I'm gonna be gone for two hours or
I'm gonna be going 49 hours right
running on a one mile track
[ __ ] I'm not crazy man it sucks I mean
you know people put me in this category
of you must be some crazy guy who loves
it no man no that's why I do it though
that's the only way to couch your [ __ ]
brain man I want me to get hard a lot
people take these classes on mental
toughness I even steals in the class
about visualization self-talk eat an
elephant one by that time breathing
control Roger that you gotta put
yourself in hellacious situation it's a
lifestyle how are you going to react how
are you gonna react
all that training goes out the [ __ ]
door when you're in the [ __ ] cold
water and you're [ __ ] miserable it's
the first hour of a hundred thirty hours
of hell week and that first wave goes
over your head and you're the codis
you've been in your life and your mind
goes from our one to our one [ __ ]
thirty all that [ __ ] self talking
[ __ ] dude you ain't think about anything
about getting the [ __ ] out of here but
if you live this [ __ ] on a daily basis
and you know how to calm your mind down
this self-talk will help all that stuff
will help but usually we react we have
pain we have suffering we react and we
react about get the [ __ ] out of here we
got to go it's those people were able to
control that [ __ ] feeling and [ __ ]
flight and say no I'm a [ __ ] there's a
way through this it's not going to be
your forever I'm not cold right now
I let the three of them I'm not cold now
I'm in a nice warm studio with you you
got to think about that [ __ ] it's just
going to end it's going to end but we
don't know that we don't think that at
that time it's gonna last forever and
then you get to sit back on Friday there
by walking across the you know back on
the grinder all the 16 17 guys that
graduated Hill week and you a chance to
watch these guys victorious
and then you get the chance think about
that you take that hot warm shower first
thing that comes to your [ __ ] minds
why the [ __ ] that I quit so what keeps
me going
I've quit several things I know what's
on the back end the [ __ ] quitting
it's a lifetime of thinking about why
[ __ ] did I do that and I ain't [ __ ]
doing that there's something about
talking to a guy like you that a lot of
people hope that you're gonna say some
magic thing that's gonna click in their
brain everybody gets change who they are
like what is it what is the thing that's
why people go to these self-help
conferences and they take these classes
and they hope that someone's gonna say
something that changes the way their
mind works it's hilarious to me it is
it's kind of hilarious to me too but
what is also hilarious is that what
you're saying is that you have to do
those things you have to suffer you have
to live in it you have to be comfortable
in it and then maybe some of that [ __ ]
will help you a little bit along the way
period and I went to I was a when I was
a still recruiter I got invited to MIT
smart ass [ __ ] there man I'm
not that I miss a garanimal Dumber
knuckle-dragger
and there was this guy that I forget his
name but he was like the top head head
guy old white guy you know all genius
doubt and we were on this panel and they
were asking us all these questions about
the mind mental toughness and [ __ ] he
was answering them and I wasn't
answering any questions now I'll never
forget he was just answering off of
theory mmm he never put his [ __ ] ass
and [ __ ] you read a bunch of [ __ ]
books and you think that you know how
the [ __ ] mind works and [ __ ] I've
gone through hell just a kid and then
all the way up until now right so I know
so that theory is [ __ ] yeah there's
a lot of good stuff out there you can
read from people but I had lived hell
and when you put yourself in hell that's
the only time you can figure out how the
[ __ ] to get through that [ __ ]
you can't you can't read somebody else's
book about some theory on how to do [ __ ]
some guy who was set up in there a nice
warm office and read and wrote some book
with a nice cup of coffee in the [ __ ]
hand no I want to see that guy who put
immersed himself in [ __ ] hell and he
thought about quitting and leaving him
and his wife and his kids and why am I
here is it is it worth it all this crazy
[ __ ] it still said if I
not a way to get through it so basically
that's that's the bottom line of it all
we all want to read about how we can
quickly get somewhere that's why that
six-minute abs and also it's so powerful
did you make it some results from it
they're not permanent
the permanent result comes from you
[ __ ] I say it all time you have to
suffer you have to make that a tattoo on
your [ __ ] brain so when that hard
time comes again you don't forget it
you may forget it for a second but you
can go back in the cookie jar call it
it's a it's something that we've all
indoors I call it the cookie jar and we
often forget how hard we are but you got
reflect back take a cup of sighs reflect
I've been through this I've been through
that and then remind yourself I'm a bad
[ __ ] and then you can get do
that [ __ ] but if you don't believe it
you ever endured [ __ ] you're just
blowing smoke man and you're not gonna
get to anything what was this guy saying
look what was his theories that he was
throwing out there his theories was
about I forget exactly what it was was
there some about what the mind does
under stress and how we can't he said
how we can't do something and I did it I
did what he said we couldn't do like
what was he saying he couldn't do it was
somebody if you're born if you're born a
certain way somebody if you're born a
certain way you can't become this way it
was totally saying that would Who I am
now like I had to be born with some not
genetic power or some some gift from God
but I had to have some kind of special
gift had to have some kinda special gift
I forget what set me off but was that we
had to be - to be somewhere you had to
be born with it what was the concept and
I know what I was born with and I know
the battle that I had in my mind so when
he said it is sad to look at my face and
some on the crowd ask me a question yeah
I totally count addicted everything he
said and I was like nah man I mean I
[ __ ] know for a fact that you can be
this [ __ ] up dude like really [ __ ]
up dude
and with the right mindset it is it
sounds so easy with the right mindset
doesn't sound easy
it's know what you're saying it sounds
very simplistic answer right you can you
can't but you have to go into the dark
chambers that we often shut off and you
got to open them up you can open up and
fight that [ __ ] demon get in there
talk to that [ __ ] and say what's
up and we often take that we all like to
take this four-lane highway the easy
highway has has [ __ ] signs it has
restaurants we all loved that four-lane
highway we always step over the shovel
and all I did was I picked up that
[ __ ] shovel and that shovel I made my
own path and you may have big boulders
and [ __ ] they may be getting towards and
miles up the road faster than you but
going through this path of life this
journey over here that you make yourself
that's incredibly difficult but it comes
out to the other end of that
[ __ ] is some glorious [ __ ]
that you can't even explain to people
and we're afraid bottom line is most of
us even the people have all these
theories and [ __ ] it's easier to accept
the fact that I'm just not good enough I
wasn't made to do that and yeah some of
us can't be LeBron [ __ ] James but
I'll tell you right now man we can do a
lot of [ __ ] when it comes to this pure
long guts and willpower and getting
through [ __ ] we have a lot more with a
lot more and we think we have yeah the
problem with a guy like that with his
theory is his theories of based on
results and those results are based on
human beings and most human beings
there's certain people that are born
with certain gifts like a guy like
LeBron James is a physical talent you
know John Jones and MMA obviously
physical talent but there's when you
look at someone who's super successful
you always assume that it has to be
because of some sort of physical gifts
because people look at themselves and
I'm sure this doctor this old dude
probably had like a little gut and
probably exactly I looked a little tiny
arms weak shoulders and probably thought
well there's certain people that are
just mesomorphic and probably broke it
down all these scientific terms right
you know they just have a fast twitch
muscle fibers and they'll say all this
crazy [ __ ] that is true
at the very highest levels of the
winners right but it doesn't mean that
you can't become that no it just means
that it's too painful for most people to
go through so very few people ever get
there so if you look at the actual
results he would be correct
but he's not correct because he doesn't
take the shovel exactly that's not the
more the story does not some easy
lit up streetlights right half with nice
smooth roads right it's a difficult
[ __ ] where you're gonna fail and
you're gonna be in your head you could
be saying I'm not good enough and it's
how you get through that is how you get
through that on a daily basis when that
thing is say man I'm 43 I've done so
much you start to become civilized the
refrigerator gets full you start getting
making money and you start I'm not
getting cold anymore I'm retired what's
in at forty people shouldn't be playing
basketball or football or beating them
up you start to believe this [ __ ] and it
becomes in your [ __ ] mind like there's
people who are retiring you know at
40-something years or 37 years old at 43
I'm still putting a hundred-mile weeks
still doing thousands of pull-ups
thousands of push-ups because I'm not
allowing myself to become civilized the
worst didn't happen to a man's become
civilized you lose that [ __ ] fight you
you you you lose that why the [ __ ] am i
doing this [ __ ] I'm good you ain't good
man you ain't never [ __ ] arrived and
that's just my mentality you may have
more but you'd never [ __ ] arrive you
want to be uncommon a most uncommon
people period uncommon amongst uncommon
people is one of the greatest ways to
put it that's it like if you're if
you're like for me what got me in
trouble with the Navy SEALs is I want to
be one so bad so bad I fought my ass off
yeah I saw them as uncommon people very
uncommon but once you become a Navy SEAL
you're all Navy SEALs so guess what
happens your [ __ ] common again I
wanted to be uncommon amongst uncommon
people I want it to be the guy I don't
care if you [ __ ] like knock if you
understand me I didn't give a [ __ ] once
I went through this [ __ ] journeys
path of life you ain't got in a whole
bunch of [ __ ] guys that don't [ __ ]
like me I don't give a [ __ ] I'm a
warrior
period who's like I've been a lot more
combat to me a Warriors not always that
words a [ __ ] who says hey I'm
here again today I'm here again tomorrow
gonna be here the next day I'm 50 years
old I'm still [ __ ] getting after it
it's a person that puts no [ __ ] limit
on what's possible and that's what got
me in trouble like that's why I went to
Ranger School as a seal that's why I try
to go to Delta Force twice you know I
bet I've been through all these
different training programs cuz I was
looking for in the military what I saw
is in the training these people get
their ass handed to him after they get
out a lot of them get civilized I always
wanted to go back in the training and I
we were always I want to go back to war
in the war was in that training program
where you see guys you can quit guys who
are brutal guys who are suffering guys
who are you go so as a seal you don't
volunteer for Ranger school I did I put
in seven chicks got turned down I get
you know got accepted I went at 28 29
years old and they go why did you go
because I started becoming civilized I
started becoming complacent I I needed
to get my [ __ ] ass kicked again and
when you go as a seal going down to it
you have no rank and Ranger school you
could be a major you're just [ __ ] Joe
Brown you're nobody and you're not
eating you're not sleeping so I always
would put myself I would immerse myself
and [ __ ] like that even IRA climb the
ladder and I intentionally fall back
down that [ __ ] to say all right
man getting soft dude getting soft kick
your [ __ ] ass again and I you know
it's kind of process did you find
resistance from that amongst other guys
that didn't like to make that you were
making them uncomfortable because that
is something that people there's a
natural instinct that people have when
someone's working harder than them to
somehow another diminish that person
well I know that a lot of guys don't
like me for a lot of reasons and I
realize that I am a guy that doesn't
care if you like me or not and when
you're an alpha male and you're against
other alpha males and we eat our own
alpha males eat their own now I love
that [ __ ] let's [ __ ] go man I want to
eat a man I'm all about that kind of
mentality
but I was sometimes take it to another
level now I went part of a of a good old
boy network I don't wanna be part I want
to be David [ __ ] gaga for too long in
my life and it got me in trouble for
time I left I wanted to be accepted
growing up
I lied I [ __ ] did what I could for if
you [ __ ] like UFC and I didn't I love
it I love it man let's go [ __ ] watch
me be my friend be my buddy
that [ __ ] weak-ass [ __ ] I found out
through this path of life who is David
Gaga's Who am I so going through all I
did it alone
there was no [ __ ] trophy on the
[ __ ] wall on the mantel that trophy
is my [ __ ] brain no one helped me get
you know I pay my [ __ ] bills no one
did [ __ ] for me no one ran those [ __ ]
miles lost that [ __ ] weight with the
hood
I suffered on my own and developed this
man who said Who I am a very competitive
ultra competitive do that take it what
you want man I call that personal
sovereignty exactly who's not a lot of
people that have that that's me and
there's a lot of people that change who
they are depending upon what people want
from them and that's that's me yeah
that's important man most people
struggle their whole life to find out
who they are
struggle their whole their whole life to
find out what defines them what they
actually enjoy and what they don't you
start putting yourself in situations
that suck you'll find yourself yeah
you'll find it real quick that is the
thing right and that's one of the things
that have gotten from paying attention
to you is that you what you're preaching
what you're talking about is finding
yourself through struggle it's it it's
only way to find yourself you don't find
yourself if you like best present and
you [ __ ] press all the [ __ ] time what
are you finding out if you like to swim
that's all you want to do is swim what
are you finding out put that in people
always I people talk about triple down
on your [ __ ] strengths right that's
the [ __ ] weakest [ __ ] in the world no
triple down on your [ __ ] weaknesses
yeah find out something about yourself
you right know that you're good [ __ ] you
know the happy [ __ ] right that's why I'm
on my Facebook page because why don't
you talk about good times you know how
to get you that [ __ ] [ __ ]
you don't need a [ __ ] you don't need
to I tell you how to get to its happy
right that's easy [ __ ] right I want to
tell you how you can help yourself get
through the times that suck real life
this is real life 90% of your life will
suck 10% will be [ __ ] happy you may
be lucky God have a lot of [ __ ] money
have a great ass woman all this [ __ ]
trust me one on one with that [ __ ]
guy he's missing something
his life still sucks that he hasn't
faced something that bothered him his
whole [ __ ] life something is still
eating that [ __ ] up almost
everybody everybody eating you the [ __ ]
up but maybe you found a good way how I
did growing up on how to ignore that
voice that's saying you ain't facing
some [ __ ] period man I'm not special I
just stopped listening I I listen to
that voice it was why I talk so [ __ ]
aggressive people said man do you
believe in God you cuss so much when I
say [ __ ] it's a is letting you know what
I'm thinking if I try to make it all
pretty and [ __ ] that's not what my life
was it was a violent violent struggle
daily to get where I'm at today I'm not
gonna water it down like a watered down
[ __ ] wasn't fun ain't fun today
I'm happy don't you think that your
happiness is probably elevated by the
amount of pain that you've gone through
a hundred percent so the amount of
suffering that you understand the amount
of pain that you've gone through makes
you appreciate the happiness and the
beautiful moments with much more
intensity that's what weak people miss
about my story weak people hear this
soft kid I'm a guy he must be miserable
oh my god what the hell is wrong with
them you're missing the [ __ ] story
you're not listening to the story man
look what I overcame if that doesn't put
some badge of honor tattooed in your
[ __ ] brain for the rest of your life
you can die today talking to Joe Rogan
you're missing the story man am I happy
what the [ __ ] do you think don't miss it
don't misunderstand the past and wish I
speak for not being intensely happy
happiest person in the world but I'm not
done
so not gonna speak to you like oh man
everything is great no I have a lot more
[ __ ] to do a lot more [ __ ] to do well
this is in the same use of the word that
you used the Warriors mentality the
Warriors life right this is this is the
way that you can keep balanced and sane
right and and keep a good grip on who
you are period and like there's a quote
that was said I don't know who said it
but was a great quote this guy said
going into combat going into war out of
the hundred men that going to war
tension you [ __ ] be there eighty of
them are this target's ten do most of or
nine do most of fighting one is a
warrior and it's a true quote to life I
saw it going through train I saw it
everywhere I went
there's so many people who just show up
to life that shouldn't even [ __ ] be
around and there's a few people who do
all the work I wanted to be part of that
nine and I'm working towards being that
one and that's how I live my life now
what are you doing with your life these
days right now I keep the same I'm very
routine I get every morning I run I go
to the gym and then at nighttime I
stretch out I am a mom just trying to
develop a business costing me a lot of
money trying to do that I'm just getting
out I'm an introvert so I never want to
get on social media I'm not big on that
I'm big on being with yourself
I believe all these [ __ ] cameras and
phones and [ __ ] it takes you away from
the most powerful thing in the world
which is your [ __ ] mind so I try hard
to continue to grow that I'm trying to
break a record again I'm trying to cross
Death Valley as fast as possible top of
Mount Whitney and I'm constantly trying
to put goals and for me but the biggest
thing is I'm trying to find more of
myself and the only way I can find more
is to silence the world out as much as I
can because it's getting busier every
day it's getting faster and the faster
it gets the more you are missing who the
[ __ ] you are so I trapped my own mind a
lot and said look man I put my phone
away I'll put [ __ ] away and I go dark I
go dark a lot and it's
because I have to find out I'm on a
journey of life and we all have a
different journey and I want to be in my
[ __ ] pine box and I believe your
spirit lives forever has too it's too
[ __ ] powerful no way in hell that
thing that's dies when you die I want to
be able to look back on my life and I'm
all dead and be so [ __ ] proud of
myself forever this is all temporary
[ __ ] to me I want to be forever proud of
who I was as a man and change who I used
to be the liar the insecure guy the guy
who can whatever I want to be proud but
if I died now if I die at 84 diet 9800 I
want to look at myself as a proud of
myself don't you think that also like we
were saying that because you've gone
through so much struggle you appreciate
happiness true happiness do you think
that you appreciate discipline because
you weren't discipline do you think you
appreciate the hard work you put in
because you used to be weak yes I
appreciate self-discipline yes I never
had a crazy thing about what you know
you say that I have a [ __ ] can
wake me up at 3 o'clock in the [ __ ]
morning and say hey you gotta get your
[ __ ] in I had no trainer I have a
nutritionist it was the self-discipline
that I had to survive not survive I was
weak to thrive no one say man you're 297
pounds man
I wanna help you out I mean you're
[ __ ] you're not smart I'm gonna help
you out I had to work at all this [ __ ] I
had to overcome and and it self
discipline is everything if you don't
have it I don't look at you right now I
know you're capable of more it's not
discipline so much for me it's all on
you it's all on you the self part it was
big we need someone to hold people
accountable [ __ ] that [ __ ] man
[ __ ] that [ __ ] we we count on people too
much to get us through [ __ ] and we look
to our right we look to our left we're
looking for help and if you can build
that self you can build that total
accountability in oneself and it's not
about being selfish I'm trying to create
a better me so hopefully people who are
hearing this are taking it the right way
can say I can run a mile anybody run a
205 [ __ ] mile doing for
Venis it ain't bout all that [ __ ] she
doesn't matter I want you to see how
[ __ ] far you can go and that's all
it's about yourself and that's where it
all comes from Willis and I guarantee
you've already done that
what you experienced from watching that
television show and with what got you
out the door what got you to sort of
take the first steps to change your life
will you experience by watching rocky
what you experience of inspiration those
are critical for people they need to
know that someone's done something that
someone's done something that's greater
than they what they could imagine
themselves doing and they want to take a
step towards trying to be better that
inspiration is gigantic and sometimes it
comes across as corny you know people
read it too much of it online it becomes
it drowns out you lose that the meaning
gets lost I mean there's and there's a
lot of posers because a lot of people
are out there that are there pretending
that they're trying to offer up
inspiration or a true honest account of
their experiences but really what
they're trying to do is say something
that's gonna get likes right you know
they're trying to say things that they
think people are gonna go yeah double
high five right you know there's a thing
that people are doing when they're just
trying to just get social cred I said
yes social media is man I'm gonna paint
you the picture of my fake life right
right right I paint you a picture of my
[ __ ] real life yeah period like it or
not man but that brought that real life
is fuel for people right it's fuel for
me I mean I died I love that [ __ ] I live
off of it there's a lot of people that I
follow online and you're one of them
that I can get something out of that I
could watch a short clip of you talking
I'm sure clips of this podcast people
gonna play these clips and go for
[ __ ] crazy runs afterwards right well
hope so
[ __ ] yeah uh-huh you don't even have to
hope it's gonna happen that's good
that's good what is this business you're
doing well it's my own Goggins LLC
basically I I'm investing in myself I'm
invested in myself and I hope that this
story is can can change somebody's life
not to be me cuz they ain't bout me and
I and I I try to be as real as I can
because we're all [ __ ]
for in this world we're all hurting and
I try to take away all titles you want
to give me that you know that I did not
come from that [ __ ] that's right to be
so authentic and so real about my own
insecurities my own faults my this being
a [ __ ] up person I'm not the best at
anything I'm not I'm not gifted
I'm just driven and it's all about
trying to share that message with people
this is all about you know I speak to a
lot of people and that's what that's
what I do now and how are you doing it
as a business I do something more of a
tional speaking but you know right now
I'm not really try making a lot of
[ __ ] money I'm just trying to build
the brand I was authentic as possible
because I don't want to build it too
fast because my biggest fear in life is
people can rewrite through a
[ __ ] that's not real I do it all
the time
like a lot of people have these great
quotes and they and they mass produce
I can't mass-produce something man Brian
and they and they had these great quotes
and [ __ ] but are you living that
[ __ ]
which you dis quoted in how powerful it
may sound are you getting up every
[ __ ] morning and I'm not working out
whatever are you really getting the [ __ ]
after are you just talking to motivate
people right and I don't want to be that
guy who are you talking to pretend that
you're exactly after and I people make
this big money over here the side which
Robin made a lot and they they talk this
[ __ ] and they're off this until it's
gone right and all Finnick a tall man
you know it's all this [ __ ] right and I
read it on my mask and [ __ ] right
[ __ ] man [ __ ] wake up get after
it live what you're saying and then it
comes people can see when I talk the
reason I talk so [ __ ] just passionate
cuz I'm reliving my [ __ ] life I'm
reliving this morning when I got up I
want to do that [ __ ] I'm reliving
everything I did it and I can't speak to
you like all calm and [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks it
sucks man so whenever I start talking
about like after this podcast you'll see
man
god you're so calm right now what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you I'm not going
back through that [ __ ] man I'm not I'm
not going back through the the suffering
and [ __ ] that it took to become Who I am
today some story so I built this brand
to the point where I can slowly
hopefully make people from motivated to
driven because motivation is crap
[ __ ] people right now maybe listen to
this [ __ ] they'll be motivated to go run
if it's closed somewhere where they're
at a lot of my first we'll shut that
door go back inside that's motivation it
comes and go as how you feel if you and
your wife are good if you and your kids
are good if you're good at work you're
motivated
I like the [ __ ] whose life is
imploded ain't got [ __ ] in life and says
I still got [ __ ] good after today man
it's what it's about so that's when you
move from motivation to driven to
obsessed and I want people to realize
once you get to this portion of over
here the driven obsessed part your
stoppable this commitment that you have
to authenticity is one of the reasons
why people are connected to what you've
met your messages that's one of the
reasons why what you're saying you don't
want to grow it too fast you don't want
it to be [ __ ] you're terrified of
that thing just like we were talking
about with weak people you terrified a
scene that weakness in yourself right
you know we all see that we've all seen
motivational things that are [ __ ]
we've all talked to people that are
talking and you realize there's nothing
really that they're connected to they're
not really connected to their words
their words just a bunch of words
they've pieced together because they
sound like something that someone who's
you know enlightened on the subject
would say right yeah it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't connect at all so
your struggle now is to try to figure
out how to stay you and get the message
out but still be fully connected to that
message right that's you know it's not
so much a struggle because I'm not
really about I'm not driven by the
business I'm not I'm not doing by trying
to be I I make a very small salary from
being retired from the military that's
all I need so I'm not fast - I'm a
minimalist [ __ ]
give me a backpack of [ __ ] ground and
sleep on and a pull-up bar and a [ __ ]
some running shoes and a Subway sandwich
with some [ __ ] and I'm [ __ ] straight
so it's um I believe in patience I'm a
patient dude I can watch the piece of
grass grow for 20 years because I know
that this is how you get somewhere in
life by being that monk-like mentality
and being able to watch something grow
very calmly patiently and that's all I'm
doing right now about monies and about
people knowing me I'll keep you like me
whoever wants to hear this is out there
so so your your goal is to grow this
right slowly very slowly and your goal
is to grow this in order to impact
people period that's it it's not about
me what do you get out of impacting
people it's a good question I don't I
don't get anything out of it I'm a tool
but you must get something there must be
personal satisfaction must be a
connection to those people there must be
it must be enriching to you it's hard to
connect with people because there's
quite a few now that are coming in right
it's my duty it's my duty to share my
it's kind like it's somebody who
discovered a new earth you know and
discover the people on it that in the
water source and the food source I
discovered a whole nother part of your
[ __ ] brain that a lot of people don't
even know about it's my job by being the
[ __ ] on this journey and being a
discovery person being the person that
maybe I discovered this part I
discovered a very important part that I
haven't met many people that have
discovered this part I'm sure there's a
lot out there but it's my job now take
these weak people in the category that I
was in and say uh-uh
stop reading the [ __ ] stop listening
to the [ __ ] and if my story of
success can impact somebody it is my job
is my duty to share this too as much as
I'm not really fond of it I I'm the kind
of guy that wants to sit in the [ __ ]
room and just be me just be me alone by
myself that's who I am I have to get
uncomfortable and tell people all this
[ __ ] you think it feels good tell me
about it I'm a fourth grade reading
level in high school I stuttered
I lied to people to be their [ __ ]
friends I didn't feel good it doesn't
feel good at all
but maybe someone's doing the same [ __ ]
and maybe they can realize wow that
[ __ ] was a piece of [ __ ] and he
[ __ ] now is a Navy SEAL
tired guy and Rosie's miles and was 297
pounds and pathetic [ __ ] and Wow
if he would say why are you talking so
it's the [ __ ] truth I was a [ __ ]
pathetic [ __ ] man people cannot
say that to themselves it's we have to
choose these great [ __ ] magical words
that that makes that make people feel
good tell yourself the truth if
something - cause you're [ __ ] fat
they may be bullying you but you might
be [ __ ] fat someone calls you dumb
it's me but you might be [ __ ] dumb
its life man take it for what it's worth
and change it and that terrible feeling
when someone does tell you they have fat
you can use that as fuel period and
that's all this is about and where it
goes if it goes somewhere and whatever
you know I don't give a [ __ ]
well you said something that I think of
when I run and it's that most people
quit at 40% I said that's not 40% rule
man I love that about 40% rule man and I
am I really developed that through my
heart surgeries and I developed that
through that first hunch at my run is I
thought I had given 100% the house on
that chair at Mile 70 I was [ __ ] up I
thought I'd given 100% and to go that
last I go man
there had this I wasn't even near 100%
so I came up with this thing called the
40% rule it's basically where you it's
like a car you put a governor on a car
and they said the car can go 130 that
governor stops the car at 91
and you're driving thinking man I want
to [ __ ] Florida but I can't go I
can't go any faster
we do it to a brain we put a governor
brain second we feel pain discomfort
suffering all those words that we hate
to say cuz we in this happy peaceful
world we live in now we stop we slow
down and if you can get through these
different barriers and gain five percent
2% 3% that 40% becomes 60 that's 60 per
kid kind of 70 and 80 and 90 and then
you're hopefully one day near a hundred
I don't I don't know many people who
probably add a hundred I mean we think
we're there but there's so much more it
isn't a hundred at death's door though
I love that I think it's true I think
that's 100% true I think when you were
laying in that tub you'd knocked on a
door that is that is a hundred percent
true no one has ever if that is our
position I didn't give a hundred percent
in that 101 mile run I did for the first
time so that's the scary thing that's
the scariest thing in the world I didn't
die you probably gave 99.99999 man dude
I don't know how to end this any better
than that so let's just wrap this up if
people want to find your stuff
what's the best place to go and look for
it
I'm just at David Goggins man social
media or Instagram Facebook I don't
tweak that much stuff out because I'm I
write these I write messages and I
always link that you know on Twitter to
my Facebook and Instagram but it's just
at David Goggins it was an honor and
privilege thanks like your lunch man I
really really really appreciate it thank
you Dave and Goggins ladies and
gentlemen go after it you [ __ ]
come on
if that doesn't fire me
[Applause]
[Music]